Also, wir stimmen mal an.
Was für ein Intro von Tobias, vielen Dank, es war fantastisch. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Folge von Das Podcast Hufo. Und vielleicht fühlt ihr euch zurückerinnert an alte Zeiten, in denen wir schon mal so aufgenommen haben, denn Stefan und ich, wir sind nicht im selben Raum. Wir sind entfernt, viele, viele tausende Kilometer trennen uns und deswegen heute wieder eine Apparatfolge. Wüsstest du, wie weit Hamburg von Köln entfernt ist? Überhaupt keine Ahnung. Ich sage 800 Kilometer. Ich sage 400 Kilometer. Köln, Hamburg, Luftlinie, heute ist die große Google-Folge auch, 357 Kilometer. Ich bin so extrem schlecht, ich bin heute in Hamburg Hauptbahnhof angekommen und aus irgendeinem Grund ging mein Internet auf meinem Handy nicht und dann dachte ich mir, fahre ich einfach mit der U-Bahn.
Noch nie gemacht, ich bin so weltfremd, ich dachte, oh, Herr Wachtmeister, ich hätte gerne eine U-Bahn-Karte, hier sind 250 Euro. Ich steige in den stählernen Wurm. Einmal in die Destination, haben Sie noch genug Kohlen dabei, Herr Wachtmeister? Und ich habe nicht mal gefunden, wo ich einsteigen muss, geschweige denn, wo ich hin muss.
Ich war den Tränen nahe, ich war so, durch dieses kurze, zehn Minuten kein Internet haben, war ich völlig, ich war wie so eine Schildkröte auf dem Rücken ohne WLAN. Ich war einfach komplett durch und dann habe ich mir ein Taxi genommen, mit einem dieser Taxifahrer, die ständig Nachfragen gestellt haben, das war schrecklich.
Und ich versuche so maximal unhöflich zu sein, wie es nur geht. Wo kommen sie her?
Und ich glaube,
als kleines Geheimtipp, wenn man unsympathisch
wirken möchte oder desinteressiert,
immer drei Sekunden Stille
vor der Antwort.
Oh wow! Wir testen es mal, wir testen es mal.
Ja, und
wo kommen Sie gerade her?
Weil hier war da auch so schönes Wetter, weil hier in Hamburg ist ja wirklich tolles Wetter heute. Aus Köln. Und du merkst, da geht gar nichts heute, da geht überhaupt nichts mehr. Du kannst aber einfach direkt antworten, aus Köln. Also es kommt noch ein bisschen auf den Ton an. Also wenn du den, du hast es gerade ein bisschen übertrieben, finde ich. Lange warten und, weil die Idee des lange Wartens ist ja, nicht unhöflich sein zu müssen, sondern ihn durch andere Signale darauf aufmerksam zu machen, dass es gerade nicht funktioniert, das Gespräch. Aber du hast gerade übertrieben. Du hast sowohl lange gewartet, als auch gesagt, ja, aus Köln. Äh, das ist schwierig. Ja, also ich führe dich mal durch den Prozess, den meine Scharade durchlebt, dadurch. Wenn ein Taxifahrer mit mir spricht, dann mache ich erst mal dieses, Moment, hören Sie das auch gerade? Jetzt habe ich irgendwie, irgendwie kommen hier Geräusche in Ihr Kraftfahrtwagen, ach das haben Sie gerade, ach so. sprechen. Sie wagen es, mit mir zu sprechen. Mit dieser Öffnung unter ihrer Nase haben Sie, ach, das ist ja putzig, das ist ja süss. Na dann, dann schaue ich mal, ob ich das auch hinbekomme, dann wollen wir doch mal ein Wortwagen. Köln. So funktioniert das. Und deswegen hast du eine Überbewertung von zwei Sternen. Und selbst dann merken die Leute nicht, dass ich keinen Bock habe zu reden. Es war interessant, heute auch interessant mal ein Erlebnis. Mein Zug ist ausgefallen und es gab einen Ersatzzug. Und dann ist der Ersatzzug auch ausgefallen. Moment, gut. Hä? Aber gibt es für ausgefallene Ersatzzug einen Ersatzzug? Ja, es gab einen Ersatzzug für den Ersat ausgefallen. Moment kurz. Und es gab ... Hä? Aber gibt's ausgefallenen Ersatzzug einen Ersatzzug? Ja, es gab einen Ersatzzug für den Ersatzzug. Also wir waren so in einer Hochzwei. Also an dem Zug stand auch ICE hoch zwei. Also man wusste einfach, okay, wir sind hier schon sehr nah am Ende. Es gibt nur noch zwei, drei Ebenen, dann ist einfach Schluss. Ist er hoch zwei schnell gefahren dann auch? Oder ist er Wur wurzel zwei schnell gefahren? Er ist auch eine komplett andere Strecke gefahren. Wir waren in einer anderen Dimension. Es hat sich so eingeknickt, er ist so nach oben direkt gestiegen, so ein Senkrechtstarter ICE, sieht man manchmal und dann wieder gestartet. Also es war interessant, ich dachte mir einfach nur so in der Leitzentrale einfach so, Chef, der Ersatzzug, er ist auch ausgefallen. Er guckt sich so um, hol den Ersatz, Ersatzzug. Hol den Ersatz, Ersatzzug, dafür haben wir geprobt, Chef. Wirklich? Ja. Hol ihn. Es war ein wilder Ritz. Und dann gibt es so einen grossen Buzzer in der Mitte des Raumes, zu dem er dann stürzen muss. Und dann muss noch so ein anderer Kollege, der die ganze Zeit an so Handschellen einen Schlüssel trägt, der muss dann auch noch hin und dann muss er es aufschliessen. Und dann geht dieses Glasding auf und dann kann ein anderer Mitarbeiter, der befugt ist, diesen großen Buzzer drücken. Man muss erst diesen Deckel aufmachen, um den Schlüssel reinzustecken und dann umzudrehen. Genau. Das würde ich gerne mal machen. Und da kommt dann ein Mitarbeiter raus, der dann den Ersatz zugerufen kann. Es gibt ja bei der, wo immer der amerikanische Präsident hinreist, gibt es ja immer diesen Koffer.
Ich glaube, der Football oder Baseball.
Ja, dieser ominöse Baseball-Koffer, ja.
Genau, und da ist ja der Knopf drin, ein portabler Knopf für Feuer, einfach mal willkürlich vier Atomraketen auf, sagen wir mal Russland.
Also die Grundeinstellung ist Russland und wenn er draufdrückt und es heißt, es muss Generationen an Secret
Vielen Dank. vier Atomraketen auf, sagen wir mal, Russland. Also die Grundeinstellung ist Russland und wenn er draufdrückt und es heißt, es muss Generationen an Secret Service Agenten geben, die immer diesen Koffer dabei haben und deren gesamter Tag daraus besteht, zu hoffen, dass sich eine Situation ergibt, wo der Präsident diesen Knopf drücken muss. Dieser Secret Service Agent hat einen Job, Hoffnung. Er steht immer dabei. Moment, ganz kurz. Oder ist es nicht seine Hoffnung, dass nichts passiert? Nein, stell dir vor, du bist da durchgegangen und du musst... Aber dann musst du doch was machen, dann musst du doch was machen. Der macht nur den Koffer auf und der Präsident haut dann drauf. Aber jeder will doch nicht arbeiten. Ja, aber die Default-Position des Menschen ist doch nichts zu tun zu müssen. Das stimmt, ich glaube die ersten vier Monate denkst du dir, ist eigentlich ein ganz entspannter Job eigentlich. Keine Ahnung, dann schüttelt der irgendwie dann die Angelegenheit. Und dann denkst du, interessant, interessant, interessant, langweilig. Genau, langweilig. Langweilig, langweilig. Wo kommt der Krieg? Hoffentlich auf Atomapokalypse. Ist es der einzige Mensch auf der Welt, der auf Apokalypse hofft eigentlich? Ich glaube schon. Ja, und halt die ganzen Prepper, die sich einen Atombunker bauen und die eigentlich nur darauf warten, dass irgendwo die Atombombe hochgeht. Ja, genau. Deren Leben ja auch daraus besteht, von allen fertig gemacht zu werden, als Vollidioten und die sich ja wahrscheinlich einfach nur selbst am Leben erhalten, mit dieser Hoffnung auf die Apokalypse und dann zum Held zu werden, als eine von die 10.000 Menschen, die überlebt haben auf der Welt. Ist eine spannende Perspektive auf jeden Fall. Ich verstehe auch Verschwörungstheoretiker total. Also das sind ja häufig irgendwie Verlierer im Leben, die dann Bock haben, sich ein Universum zu kreieren, in dem diejenigen, die die Erleuchteten sind, die Helden. Das verstehe ich total. Ich glaube, eine Verschwörungstheorie zu glauben, ist ökonomisch gesehen das Beste, was man machen kann. Du hast sofort die gesamte Welt verstanden, du gehörst sofort einem Kreis erhobener Persönlichkeiten an, die die Wahrheit durchschaut haben, du hast sofort einen Antagonismus zu allen Menschen, die du hast, weil irgendwie dein dummer Chef, ah, das ist so ein Schlafschaf, der checkt's nicht, die sind alle Schlafschafe, die dummen Politiker sind eh korrupt. Du hast sofort die Welt erklärt und was musst du machen? Du musst dir halt drei schlecht geschnittene Videos auf YouTube angucken und du hast alles verstanden. Das ist perfekt, das Beste, was man machen kann. In gebrochenem Englisch, genau, du weißt nicht genau, ja, das ist spannend, du schaffst sofort dein Selbstwertgefühl, um eine Milliarde mal zu steigern, du schaffst es sofort, alle Fragen zu beantworten, du hast keine Fragen mehr, du bist der cleverste Mensch, genau, anteilig an einem lesenden Kreis, das ist wirklich spannend. Und ich glaube, das macht total Sinn. Und das kostet halt auch nichts. Das geht auch sehr schnell, ich finde das total clever. Und ich finde alle blöd, die es nicht machen, um ehrlich zu sein. Vielleicht macht es uns auch doof jetzt, weil die Lösung ist so klar. Es geht ja nur darum, sein Selbstwertgefühl zu steigern. Ich verstehe. Aber auch Verschwörungstheoretiker sind wahrscheinlich die Leute, die den ganzen Tag darauf hoffen, einmal sagen zu können, na, hab ich's doch gesagt. Die versprühen Chemikalien doch im Himmel. Jetzt ist rausgekommen und 99,9 Prozent der Welt so, oh nein, bitte sag nicht, dass die Recht haben. Ja, vor allem ist das eine Frage, dass die Recht haben. Warum müssen denn jetzt die Flat-Earth-er-Recht haben? Das waren die unsympathischen von allen.
So, aber der arme Wissenschaftler, der vor die Weltöffentlichkeit tritt und sagt, ja, wir haben da doch nochmal diesen einen Test gemacht mit dem Heißluftballon und dann. Ja, und Exenmenschen existieren. Ist doch flach, ist doch, ist doch flach, ja, ja, ja, sorry. Und Harald Lesch schüttelt nur so enttäuscht den Kopf, aber ja, es ist, ja, sorry. Und hier kommt sein großes Entschuldigungsvideo? Kommt dann der Rücktritt von Harald Lesch eigentlich? Ich glaube, der muss unter Tränen zurücktreten und nimmt seinen Hut, baut die Tafel ab. Nimmt seinen Hut und sein Globus nimmt dann mit. Ja, genau. Und dann war es das. Nimmt seine Kaffeetasse und seinen Stuhl und geht nach Hause. Ja, um dann was zu tun. Ja, das ist ja so das Problem, was macht man dann. Baum mit so einem Strick. Naja, was soll denn dann passieren? Ich glaube, halt, Harald, vielleicht will ich nichts mehr an das glauben. Dann ist ja ledigliche Autorität untergraben. Ja, es ist so schwierig, was macht man dann so? Das ist ja auch so, zum Beispiel, es gibt ja auch so eine Mörderin, also eine ganz bekannte Serienmörderin, die hat irgendwie ganz viele Leute umgebracht und war dann im Gefängnis und hat sich dann so gedacht, so jetzt bin ich im Gefängnis, was mache ich jetzt?
Ich bin bekannt, ja alle kennen mich als Mörderin, aber ich kann aus dieser Popularität nicht viel schöpfen, weil ich bin halt im Gefängnis.
Und die hat ein Kochbuch gemacht, aus dem Gefängnis raus, hat die ein Kochbuch geschrieben, was sich natürlich verkauft hat, weil ich meine, du gehst in einen Kochbuchladen und es gibt tausend Kochbücher von generischen Köchen und natürlich willst du das Kochbuch von der Massenmörderin haben. Von der Kannibalin das Kochbuch haben. Ja, genau. Menschenblutwurst zum Beispiel, Menschenleber, Menschenleber scharf angebraten, venezianisch. Ja, stimmt schon, Aber auch da immer so diese Zweitkarrierenplan, das ist immer so ein Ding. Ich glaube auch, wie gesagt, ich glaube auch Edward Snowden könnte nochmal ein super gutes so ein irgendwie Cocktailbuch rausbringen oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, so eine Zweitkarriere. Nein, kein Cocktailbuch, nee so Studentenfutter oder ich traue dem eher etwas Nerdiges zu. Aber das finde ich ja spannend, weil oft zu den Kochbüchern auch immer dann die Rezepte, Geschichten zu den Rezepten, wo, auf welcher Reise sie dieses Rezept kennengelernt haben und so weiter. Und das würde ich gerne wissen von ihr. Irgendwie so nach dem, nach meinem dritten Mord hatte ich richtig Lust auf Eis. Und wo findet man so ein schönes Eis, richtig? Was sind Ihre Texte dazu? Das ist ja eigentlich immer das schönste am Morden eigentlich danach, so ein richtig schönes Ragout. So richtig, wirklich mit dem richtigen Wein. Und da hatte ich Lust auf Ratatouille, denn nichts bringt meine Nerven runter, mehr als ein schönes Ratatouille nach so einem schönen Dreifachmord. Die Familie schreit noch im Keller. Ja. Aber weisst du, was ich letztens herausgefunden habe? Manchmal mag man ja Dinge und man weiß gar nicht so genau, warum man sie mag. Und dann irgendwann versteht man, ah, ich mag das deswegen. Und ich bin ja ein großer Freund der Badewanne, ich bade gerne. Und letztens, und dann denkt man sich, ah, es ist entspannt, weil es so warm ist und so, oder weil man sich so leicht fühlt wegen Auftrieb oder so. Keine Ahnung, ist schwer zu beschreiben, warum man das so gerne mag. Oder weil man sich fühlt wie Mutterleib oder so, dann versucht man so ein bisschen, keine Ahnung, in der Jugend zu graben. Warum mag ich das so gerne? In der Jugend? Weil man in der Jugend im Mutterleib natürlich. Ich weiß, du hast eine weirde Jugend gehabt. Ich habe mit elf habe ich nicht mehr entschlossen, ich ziehe nochmal zurück ein bei Mama einfach nochmal. Ich ziehe nochmal ein Jahr lang ein in Mutterleib einfach. Einmal nochmal rein. Einmal nochmal in die Jugendwohnung.
Ist mir aber ein Punkt aufgefallen, warum ich Baden so liebe, und zwar nach so einem richtig langen, heissen Bad hat man wahnsinnigen Durst.
Ja, das stimmt. Und nichts ist besser, als extremen Durst zu haben.
Und natürlich legt man sich davor schon mal so eine Literflasche ins Kühlfach und du hast brutalen Durst und dann vernichte ich auch manchmal einfach so eine Ein-Liter-Flasche in einem Zug. Und das ist ja das beste Gefühl der Welt, eine grosse Notlage aufzulösen. Und deswegen wirklich, also ich glaube, wenn es eine Tablette gäbe und wenn man die nimmt, kriegt man extrem Durst. Das wäre so eine Art Droge, weil es ist extrem befriedigend, diesen Durst zu löschen. Gut, Salz, sagst du jetzt. Sport, sage ich jetzt. Gut, aber da muss man sich, da muss ich noch bemerken. Aber das zeugt auch davon, dass du viel zu heiß badest. Viel zu heiß. Dass du so viel schwitzt während des Badevorgangs, dass du danach so viel Flüssigkeit zunehmen musst. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum man da so viel Durst hat, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich finde es spannend und ich werde auch immer schamloser, was Baden angeht, weil irgendwann hat man ja Hobbys durchgespielt. Ja, jetzt nur noch in Unterhose, so ich gehe all in. Und letztens dachte ich mir so, lag ich in der Badewanne und dachte mir, Alter, wie geil sind eigentlich Gewürzgurken? Und dann dachte ich mir, Moment mal, ich habe ein Glas Gewürzgurken in der Küche. Ich habe acht Gläser, ich kann in Gewürzgurken baden. Ich dachte mir, fuck it, geh in die Küche, hol mir ein Glas Gewürzgurken und hab in der Badewanne ein Glas Gewürzgurken vernichtet einfach. Ich hab's mir einfach reingezogen.
Oh mein Gott, du hast auf.
Ich dachte mir, wer hält mich davon ab? Niemand. Ja, das sag ich doch auch. Du bist ein erwachsener Mensch, man kann machen, was man will. Hatten wir es neulich auch davon, dass ein Kollege von mir nachts nicht schlafen konnte und rausgegangen ist? Ich denke da nach wie vor drüber nach. Ja, man vergisst das manchmal. Wir sind erwachsene Menschen, Florentin. Wir können machen, was wir wollen. Es ist alles möglich. Ich kann jetzt diese Podcastaufnahme beenden. So, ich kann jetzt hier auf diesen Knopf drücken und ...
Wiederkommen auch, ist gar kein Problem.
Siehst du, ich kann alles machen.
Ich war jetzt kurz draußen.
Du kannst alles machen, das ist fantastisch.
Wirklich, ich kann es nur empfehlen.
Es ist herrlich, vor allem so wirklich so mal richtig nachts draußen sein.
So drei Uhr nachts.
Und vor allem ist es ja auch was ganz anderes, ob du draußen bist, um wohin zu kommen,
oder ob du ohne Ziel draußen bist.
Du hast kein Ziel!
Richtig!
Ja, ich bin einfach da, bin einfach da, ich stehe auf der Strasse.
Auch mal so zu embracen, dass gerade etwas keinen Zweck hat und auch die eigene Existenz ja keinen Zweck hat.
Einfach nur mal das verinnerlichen und dann dem auch mal, weiss ich nicht, dem erliegen.
Ich finde das ja ganz spannend. Das ist auch so eine neue Phase in meinem Leben vielleicht. Die Sinnlosphase. Ja, es ist alles egal. Nichts hat Konsequenzen. Oh, ich hatte fast einen ganz dollen Unfall neulich. Ich bin morgens, wir drehen ja gerade, und ich bin morgens um fünf Uhr dreissig von Köln nach Bonn gefahren. Und das ist eine Zeit, in der man nicht Auto fahren sollte. Generell nicht, weil man selber so an Sekundenschlafschüben
leidet, weil der menschliche Körper
nicht dafür gemacht hat, um 35 aufzuschieben, meiner jedenfalls nicht.
Und dann
ist vor mir, war so ein typischer Handwerker-Van,
so ein Sprinter.
Und der ist einfach eingeschlafen.
Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären, denn der ist einfach
geradeaus in die Leitplanke
gefahren. Direkt vor mir.
Der ist direkt vor mir und es war auf der Autobahn, ich hatte irgendwie 160 Sachen drauf, der vor mir auch, Es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehrplanke gefahren, direkt vor mir, der ist direkt vor mir und es war auf der Autobahn, ich hatte irgendwie 160 Sachen drauf, der vor mir auch, ist dann eingeschlafen, ist dann wirklich in die Leitplanke reingefahren und ist dann, war er dann kurz, war er auf der Kippe, ob der umkippt oder nicht. Er ist dann aber rechts wieder auf die Fahrbahn gekommen und ist dann rechts über die Spuren geschlittert, hinten hat sich dann mit warmem Blindlicht auf den Bremsstreifen rechts gestellt.
Und das war wirklich gefährlich, weil wenn er umgekippt wäre, was kurz so aussah, dann wäre mein Bremsweg viel zu kurz gewesen, ich wäre einfach in den Reingefahren. Und dann war es das, dann wäre es das mit Podcast-Ufo gewesen. Aber tatsächlich hatte ich dann irgendwie Glück und konnte auch rechtzeitig bremsen, die hinter mir haben auch aufgepasst, alles gut, er ist auch irgendwie glücklich davon gekommen, dem ging es auch gut, ich habe dann reingeguckt, als ich dann langsam wieder angefahren bin, er hat dann auch Warenblendlicht angemacht und so weiter, dann ist er noch ausgestiegen, war alles gut, aber das war so kurz der Moment, wo ich dachte, ja, das wäre es fast gewesen und man hört das ja häufig von Menschen, diese klischeehaften, das war's Momente, Nahtoderungen und so weiter. Und die haben danach ein neues Leben angefangen. Nein, ich bin danach direkt weiter zur Arbeit gefahren. Schönen McDrive, einfach noch ein Fishmilk. Fuck it, fuck it. Fuck it, ich bin einfach zur Arbeit gefahren und habe mein Leben weitergelebt und habe auch nicht mit vielen an dem Platz darüber gesprochen. Das ist meine Art, mit dem nahenden Tod umzugehen, ist einfach genauso weiterzumachen, weil es ja auch im Endeffekt, ja, natürlich kann das passieren, aber auch wenn nicht, dann ist doch, ich lebe ja schon das Leben, was ich lebe, also auch vielleicht eine interessante Erkenntnis, man lebt ja vielleicht schon das Leben, was man leben würde, wenn man nächsten Tag sterben würde. Aber es ist so interessant, weil auf die solchen Nahtoderfahrungen kann man zwei komplett gegenläufige Reaktionen haben. Weil zum Beispiel auch dieser Ausspruch YOLO kann man auf zwei komplett unterschiedliche Arten deuten. Man kann entweder sagen, you only live once, also mach was du willst, weil das Leben ist kurz, oder du lebst nur einmal, also sei fucking vorsichtig, weil du hast nur ein Leben. Und es sind zwei komplett gegenläufige Ergebnisse, die aber aus der gleichen Erfahrung resultieren. Also es ist ganz merkwürdig. Aber es gibt, ausser dann gibt es natürlich noch dich, der nach einer Nahtoderfahrung macht, ich mache so weiter wie bis jetzt. Ich mache so weiter. Yolo, ich mache einfach so weiter wie bis lang. Ich frage mich ja, also wie ist Yolo denn eigentlich gemeint? Yolo ist doch gemeint, ähm, Yolo ist halt Carpe Diem, so, geniesse jeden Moment. Aber es kann auch, aber Carpe Diem ist das cleverere Yolo, weil es natürlich, es klingt weniger cool, muss man sagen, weil Latein auch tot ist auf eine Art, ist meine Meinung jedenfalls, aber auf der anderen Seite ist es klarer als Yolo, weil wie du schon sagst, Yolo kann unterschiedlich gedeutet werden. Wie ist denn gemeint eigentlich? Ist doch gemeint, mach das Beste draus. Ja, ich glaube, ist schon so gemeint, ist eh egal. Gib vollgas. Do it for the laugh. Ja, schwierig. Diffel. Diffel klingt halt auch scheiße. Dance like nobody's watching finde ich immer noch am besten. Ja, oder watch like nobody's dancing, je nachdem. Also es gibt auch da verschiedene Ausführungen. Ist völlig richtig. Aber wie gesagt, Sprichwörter sind eh so ein Ding. Ich glaube, Sprichwörter sind so wie so Zitate. Es gibt für jede Gelegenheit ein Zitat und man kann es immer rausnehmen. Also angenommen, jemand sagt, oh, deine Wohnung ist ganz schön unordentlich. Und dann kann man so ein Zitat sagen wie, ja, Genies leben im Chaos oder so. Von Peter Ul, ist nicht so ein bekanntes Zitat, aber hat er tatsächlich gesagt. Oder jemand sagt, wow, deine Wohnung ist ganz schön aufgeräumt, dann kann man auch sagen, ja, ein Genie lebt in Ordnung, auch von Peter Ulrich. Wie gesagt, schwierig, sehr wenig Leser seine Bücher. Und ich kenne auch nur einen Menschen, ja. Wie gesagt, man kann alles untermauern, egal was man will. Das ist eine Altswerkwaffe. Ja, das ist eine Altswerkwaffe. Ich finde auch überholt mittlerweile, weil die sich auch ausgleichen kontinuierlich. Ich suche immer noch nach diesem einen Sprichwort, wo es kein Pendant zu gibt auf der Gegenseite. Es gibt ja immer eine dunkle Seite der Macht, Zitat, und eine helle Seite der Macht, Zitat. Okay, dann sag ich dir jetzt ein Sprichwort und du sagst mir das Sprichwort, das das exakte Gegenteil ausdrückt. Ja, hier zum Beispiel, Unterschiede ziehen sich an, zum Beispiel, und dann gibt es auch, was ich lieb, das neckt sich. Ja. Und du sollst keine schlafenden Hunde wecken. Und wache Hunde. Lass die Hunde mal schlafen. Who let the dogs out? Who, who, who, who, who. Okay, ich sag dir ein Sprichwort und du sagst mir das Sprichwort, das das genaue Gegenteil erzeugt, okay? Ja, ja. Wer anderen eine Grube gräbt, fällt selbst hinein. Fällt selbst hinein. Das wäre ja jetzt quasi, wenn du anderen etwas antust, kriegst du es, also es ist ja quasi eigentlich, wie es in den Wald schallt, schallt es auch zurück, ne? Das wäre das gleiche Sprichwort, das wäre auf der gleichen Ebene. Dann sowas wie der kategorische Imperativ zum Beispiel, ja auch auf der gleichen Ebene. Oder was du nicht willst, dass man das wirklich auch einem anderen zu tut. Eigentlich gibt es sehr viele Sprichwörter, die das sagen. Ja, muss ich passen. Du hast das einzelne Sprichwort gefunden. Es ist schwierig auch, was da die genaue gegenteilige Bedeutung ist. Also was man anderen antut, passiert einem selbst.
Kriegt man auch zurück, ja, Wie ist in den Wald schalt? Ja, es ist schon ... Das andere Beispiel wäre sowas wie, die gegenteilige Behauptung wäre sowas wie, mach was du willst. So der einzige, der dir im Weg steht, bist du selbst so. Kümmere dich nicht um andere. Genau, Dinge haben keine Konsequenzen, mach was du willst. Arschlöcher kommen weiter im Leben vielleicht auch, sowas. Ja, genau so so. Wer es nicht versucht, der hat es gar nicht erst probiert. Wer es probiert, muss es nicht erst noch versuchen. Ich finde ja immer noch lustig, dass man sagt, an dem geschenkten Gaul schaut man nicht ins Maul, aber dann gibt es sowas wie die Sage von dem Toyanischen Krieg und dem Toyanischen Pferd, wo die doch auch gesagt haben müssen, Leute, am geschenkten
Maul sollte man wohl sehr wohl
ins, man sollte, es gibt doch ein Sprichwort
dafür. Ja, ganz Troja
musste erst fallen, damit wir diese
Lektion lernen, dass man geschenkten
Gäulern doch bitte schon ins Maul
schaut. Ins fucking Maul schauen sollte.
Das ist nämlich der Feind, das sind die
scheiss Spartaner.
Nee. Doch. Naja. Die Griechen. Ja, die Griechen, sorry. Wo ist denn Troja? Ja, das ist ja verschollen. Da gab es ja dann in den 1890ern dann so, oh, hier wurde Troja gefunden. Achso, ich dachte, in den 1890ern ist Troja gefallen.
Die haben sich noch so ein bisschen über Wasser gehalten, aber ...
Bis in die 80er, ja.
Ja, dann wurde irgendwann Troja gefunden und dann hieß es, jopp, jetzt haben wir es, passt, ciao.
Ich habe gerade mal gegoogelt, weil wir machen eine tolle Skype-Folge immer wieder, wie man hört, weil wir uns auch ins Wort fallen.
Und jeder kennt doch diesen tollen Skype-Jingle.
Dim dim dim, dudelum, dim dim dim, dudelum, dim dim dim, mega Jingle. Ich wollte mal herausfinden, wer hat denn eigentlich geschrieben? Übrigens nochmal vielen Dank an Tobias für das tolle Intro, denn mein persönliches Lieblings-Intro von dieser heutigen Folge war nämlich das Skype-Intro, was ich gehört habe, als du mich angerufen hast. Und es ist von Peter Rayburn. Peter Rayburn is a British composer, music producer and songwriter. He is well known for his work with the director Jonathan Glazer, Sexy Beast, Birth, Under the Skin, und er hat halt auch die Musik für Skype gemacht. Er hat die berühmte Skype, den berühmten Skype-Dschingel geschrieben. Er hat noch viele andere Sachen gemacht. Adidas, Ikea, Land Rover, Audi, Playstation Vita, Guinness, Ford, Sony Walkman, Playstation 2. Krass, aber Peter Rayburn, den kann man mal so merken. Und der hat, glaube ich, sogar das attraktive Frauen-Hinterherpfeifen komponiert, dieses ... Das ist von dem. Von wem ist das eigentlich? Das ist auch von Peter Rayburn. Peter Rayburn. Ja, das ist dieses Oh la la. Und von ihm ist auch, glaube ich, Komma. Ja, und von ihm ist auch Nene, nene, nene, nene. Wow, wow, wow. Ist zum Glück alles Gema-frei mittlerweile. Peter fucking Rayburn, weil er so eine Gamer-freie Bibliothek angelegt hat. Auch das klassische Anklopfen. Ja, oh, das ist dieses Stück. Ja, Triole. Ja, sehr schön. Wahnsinn. Alles von ihm. Also der hat wirklich so, so viel geleistet. Und fast niemand kennt seinen Namen. Was tragisch ist, was unter anderem auch zutrifft, auf den Kontinent Afrika.
Afrika, Afrika.
Afrika, so viel für uns getan und niemand kennt sich damit aus. Ich habe eine Nachricht von einer Hörerin bekommen, die ist in einem Sprachkurs mit einer Afrikanerin und die ist dann auch mit ihr aneinander geraten, weil sie ihr aufgefallen ist, dass sie keine Ahnung hat, was in Afrika überhaupt los ist und es schwer für sie ist, ein Gespräch über Afrika zu führen, weil sie sagt, ich weiß, worum es geht. Und vielen geht es so und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht, es liegt natürlich auch in unserer Hand. Deswegen fahren Florentin und ich nächstes Jahr,
ab nächstem Jahr für drei Jahre nach Afrika, reisen da rum und...
Was ist jetzt eine afrikanische Melodie? Ich bin gespannt. Antenne asynchron. Antenne asynchron, ja, sie hören Antenne delay, delay, delay. Ich habe neulich tatsächlich Toto von Africa, Africa von Toto gesungen bei einem Karaoke-Abend, weil ich nicht wusste, weil jeder musste singen und ich wusste nicht, was ich singe. Was wäre dein Go-To-Song? Ich dachte dann irgendwann Africa, weil das ist halt so ein Song, du solltest ein Song, ich habe vorher dann auch gegoogelt, How to Survive Karaoke Night. Und der erste Tipp war, nimm einen Song, den jeder kennt. Weil, und sei nicht der Erste, der singt, sondern sing irgendwann, wenn alle betrunken sind, und dann singen schon alle irgendwie mit. Ja, genau. Africa ist der perfekte Song. Africa hat eine zu grosse Range, also der Ambitus, die Differenz vom höchsten Ton zum tiefsten Ton ist viel zu gross, das muss man sagen, großes Problem, lange Strophen, man kennt gewisse C-Teile nicht, ist ein problematischer Song, hat sich aber als trotzdem gut herausgestellt, weil alle mitsingen, das ist ganz gut. Ein anderer Bekanter hat Emanuela gesungen von Fettes Brot. Das hat gar nicht funktioniert.
Da singt nämlich niemand mit, Rap ist generell blöd, man kann den Zeichen unten nicht folgen und Emanuela hat Songteile, die ich in meinem Leben noch nicht gehört habe. Deswegen... Von Liebe, von Liebe weiss nicht. Bis dahin kennt man den Song, dann ist vorbei. Mal wieder ausgetrickst. Danach weiss niemand mehr weiter. Bis dahin singen auch noch alle mit und danach ist ein großes, ne, ja, ich gehe mal kurz zur Bar. Und dann stehst du da auf der Bühne und musst Emanuela bis zu Ende singen. Problematisch. Deswegen, Karaoke Night, immer einen Song nehmen, den jeder kennt. Und nicht sowas langes wie Bohemian Rhapsody. Du willst durchkommen. Nee, das ist auch wirklich nur für die Angeber, die Bohemian Rhapsody haben. Aber du hast schon recht, je mehr Leute mitsingen, desto weniger fällt dein Gesang auf. Kleiner Tipp, für mich auch, was immer, finde ich, gut funktioniert, ist Back to Black von Amy Winehouse. Jetzt nicht so ein Gröler, aber relativ leicht zu singen und ich habe das Gefühl, also zumindest für mich sind oft tiefe Frauenstimmen am einfachsten zu singen. Und ich glaube, das geht glaube ich vielen so, weil es ist halt eine Frauenstimme hoch, aber die tiefe Frauenstimme.
Da glaube ich, kommen die meisten ran. Deswegen Back to Black von Eddie White aus wenig Noten. Advanced Tipp für dich dann, ein Song von einem Mann. Ein Song aus deinem Geschlecht. Weil man sich zum Beispiel gar nicht singen kann, ist Frank Sinatra. Komme ich überhaupt nicht hin. Gar nicht. Das ist kein Problem, Florian. Da musst du gar keine Angst haben.
Die wenigsten können so singen wie Frank Sinatra.
Das muss dir nicht peinlich sein.
Das musst du nicht mit hochrotem Kopf, musst du das jetzt nicht sagen.
Ja, okay.
Also, aber wir stecken mitten in Antenne Afrika.
Und wir haben offensichtlich so wenig Ahnung.
Sorry, wir reden übereinander, weil wir Probleme haben mit dem Internet. Werbung. Oh, Stefan, findest du es nicht auch nervig, dass man ständig sein komplettes Geld in bar mit sich rumtragen muss? Es gibt das Konzept einer Bank und es gibt sogar das noch bessere Konzept der Commerzbank, denn da kannst du jetzt ein eigenes Girokonto eröffnen in wenigen Minuten. Das ist Deutschlands schnellstes, erschnellbares Girokonto.
Ja und wie viele Tausend Euro kostet es, da ein Konto aufzumachen? Das kostet gar nichts. Es entfällt alles, sogar sämtliche Kontoführungsgebühren entfallen bei ausschliesslicher digitaler Nutzung.
Zusätzlich gibt es 100 Euro Startguthaben und eine Kreditkarte von Mastercard dazu on top. Stopp, ich kriege Geld von der Bank, wenn ich ein Konto aufmache. Richtig, und wenn du das Ganze weiterempfehlst an Familie oder Freunde, gibt es nochmal 100 Euro on top. Das Beste ist, ihr könnt einfach auf ufo.commerzbank.de gehen, um das Ganze auszuchecken, alle Informationen herauszufinden und all das zu tun, was wir euch gerade erklärt haben, ein wenig mutendes Konto zu erstellen und es ist ein komplett eigenes, kostenfreies Jivo-Konto. Herzlich willkommen zu Antenne Afrika! Afrika, Afrika. Lala! Nee. Arriba! Ja, ihr habt keine Ahnung, was in Afrika so los ist. Arriba Afrika. Da ist die Rubrik. Arriba Afrika. Hola. Afrika alle. Vielleicht habt ihr keine Ahnung, was in Afrika so los ist. Und das wollen wir natürlich ändern, denn die Podcast-UFO-Gemeinschaft hält ihre Hände über den gesamten Globus hinweg.
Wir haben überall unsere Informanten und unsere Leute.
Und egal, welche Wissenslücken wir haben, die Podcast-UFO-Community kann sie stopfen.
So zum Beispiel Yannick. Yannick lebt in Windhöck.
Ah ja, Südafrika.
Und das ist die Hauptstadt von welchem Land?
Südafrika? Nein. Das macht ja keinen Sinn. Das ist doch ... Namibia. Was? Windhög ist kein Witz. Windhög ist die Hauptstadt von Namibia. Und da wohnt Yannick, und Yannick hat unser Rumgestammel mit Mitleid angehört und hat sich dazu entschlossen, uns mal so ein kleines Update zu geben, was Namibia eigentlich ausmacht, was man in Namibia so macht und was er in Namibia so erlebt hat. Und da wir natürlich gerne uns weiterbilden wollen im Thema Afrika, Thema Namibia, kommt jetzt hier ein kleiner Exkurs zu dem fantastischen Land Namibia.
Warte, ganz kurz, bevor du anfängst, würde ich gerne die Nationalhymne von Namibia anmachen.
Es fängt an mit Namibia.
Das ist fantastisch. We are God, glory to the bravery, who are the waters of freedom.
. The glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, the glory of the Lord, Wo der Geschehn auf dem Tief tritt, da die jahre auf dem Tief, da die jahre auf dem Tief schiebt. Unendliche Weiten, abenteuerliche Natur, am Horizont trabt eine Gazelle entlang, wo ich hinschaue, kilometerweit nichts zu sehen, so ist sie, die Wüste Afrikas. Nein, um ehrlich zu sein, stehe ich gerade mitten in Windhoek, der Hauptstadt Namibias. Auch hier, im südlichen Afrika, gibt es abseits der Wüstenregion pulsierende Grossstädte mit modernen Shoppingmalls und zahlreichen Hochhäusern. Ich möchte die Gelegenheit nutzen, das Bild über Afrika oder zumindest über Namibia etwas zurechtzurücken. Denn in den eineinhalb Minuten, in denen sich Florentin und Stefan über Namibia unterhalten, werden eklatante Wissenslücken deutlich, über die sich die beiden auch selber lustig machen. Und zumindest der Frage, ob man in Namibia Namibisch spricht, möchte ich hiermit mal auf den Grund gehen. Kurz gesagt, nö, das ist tatsächlich völliger Blödsinn. In Namibia ist die Amtssprache Englisch, und es gibt acht weitere Nationalsprachen.
Eine davon ist Deutsch, weil Namibia einst deutsche Kolonie war und viele Freunde der
guten alten Kolonialzeit immer noch hier leben. Ich habe verschiedene Menschen nach Witzen in
ihrer Sprache gefragt, und ich hoffe, euch so drei Sprachen aus Namibia etwas näher bringen zu können.
Das war Damarana Ma. One day there was a marathon, running against Jekyll and Kate, but at the end, the Kate was the winner. Das war Otschi Herero. Let us arrange ourselves like, ok, the first bullet will kill you, the second one will attack you,
and once the German is busy to load the other bullets, they hit the German with the Kiri.
That's why we have so lots of guns, it was only through that how we capture the guns from the Germans and and and and for them so briefly.
Historie wordt vertel van Kali Knutse, Mike Skitte en Koos van der Merwe wat in a kroeg instap. Toe vraag die kroegman vir hulle watse grappe sediri. Das war Afrikaans. It's very short. What it actually means is the three people I mentioned in this joke is that it's usually the people that they make jokes off. Was das eigentlich bedeutet, ist, dass die drei Leute, die ich in diesem Schuss erwähnte,
sind, dass es meistens die Leute, die Schuss machen.
Diese drei Leute gehen in die Bar und die Barmann fragt, was dieser Schuss ist das? Dann könnt ihr ja das Podcast-Ufo mal in Occiherero anmoderieren. Oh, wie fantastisch. Ey, ja, vielen Dank. Was für ein toller Beitrag ist das denn gewesen?
Ey, mega gut, Janne, großartig.
Oh, wie das ist wirklich, ich würde auch sagen, weil ich das wirklich, das liegt mir wirklich am Herzen und es trifft mich selber immer wieder, wenn man auf das Thema Afrika kommt und wie wenig man weiß, jetzt mal alle Länder vorzustellen mit Hilfe von euch. Das heisst, wenn ihr irgendwo seid, ich finde das eine tolle Idee, dann schickt uns gerne einen Beitrag aus eurem Land, wo ihr gerade seid, in Afrika, wo auch immer. Und dann stellen wir vielleicht nach und nach, können wir so vielleicht Afrika ein bisschen näher bringen. Ich finde das toll. Ich finde das großartig. Ich meine, vielleicht haben wir tatsächlich in jedem Land Afrikas einen Hörer. Und ich meine, Afrika hat 55 Länder, von daher es kann eine Weile dauern, bis wir alle durch haben. Aber ich fände es toll, die mal alle so kennenzulernen und Namibia nicht schlecht. Ich finde es aber auch ganz geil, dass wir Namibia als völlig willkürliches Land in Afrika genannt haben und wir nehmen natürlich ein Land, in dem die Deutschen Völkermord begangen haben, ist natürlich klar, egal wohin man kommt, man kennt uns schon Deutschland, Deutschland verbindet.
Wenn ihr in anderen Ländern Afrikas lebt oder da zu Besuch seid, dann lasst uns mal hören, was ihr da so betreibt den ganzen Tag.
Egal wo ihr seid, ob ihr seid in Elfenbeinküste, Kongo, Mali, Marokko, Marokko, Ägypten, Tunesien, Algerien, Südafrika, Westsahara, Mittelafrika, Äthiopien, Djibouti, Äthiopien, Kenia. Wow, wir sind grosse Fans. Also wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste, was mein Lieblingsland in Afrika ist. Oder auch Russland, wir sind grosse Fans. Ich könnte es nicht. Ich könnte es nicht entscheiden. Tatsächlich, vielen Dank an Yannick, weil der hat uns nicht nur diesen fantastischen Beitrag zugeschustert, sondern er hat auch dafür gesorgt, dass nicht nur Namibia zu uns kommt, sondern wir auch nach Namibia kommen, denn wir sind ja im namibischen Radio zu hören mittlerweile, wo Yannick arbeitet. Und das Podcast-Ufo fliegt also auch nach Afrika und landet dort. Und jetzt denkt ihr euch wahrscheinlich, oh, also ich meine, haben wir da überhaupt eine Chance im namibischen Radio gegen die ganze Konkurrenz, die da herrscht? Also können wir da überhaupt auch nur ein oder zwei Hörer oder so an den Apparat fesseln? Gibt es da nicht viel zu krasse Konkurrenz dort in Namibia. Zu dem Thema hat uns auch ein Hörer eine Nachricht geschickt und mal so einen kleinen Eindruck gegeben, was in Namibia denn so normalerweise im Radio läuft. Und praktischerweise, wie auch schon angesprochen wurde, wird in Namibia auch deutsch gesprochen. Das heißt, wir können das sogar verstehen. Nein! Wir hören mal ganz kurz rein, was so im namibischen Radio normalerweise läuft. Oder aber von 8.30 Uhr bis 16 Uhr im United House-Zentrum. Dann heute noch die Sonderspendeplätze, einmal in Rundu von 12 bis 17 Uhr im Galaxy-Einkaufszentrum. In Windhoek, das ging schon um 9 Uhr los, geht noch bis 15 Uhr bei Bank Windhoek, Main Branch. Und ins Ballfisch hat auch um neun bereits angefangen, geht noch bis 16 Uhr bei Ramos Rialtes Namibia. Und merken Sie sich schon mal vor, für morgen, Donnerstag, der 13. Juli, kann man in Rundu wiederum von neun bis fünfzehn Uhr spenden beim Vocational Training Center, in Windhoek von 9-15 Uhr bei Bank Windhoek,
bei Lipscher Insurance und in Walfischbucht Radio wird über Blutspenden gesprochen die ganze Zeit. Aber es wirkt auch nicht wirklich gut vorbereitet, sondern mehr so abgelesen. Ja, vielen Dank an Chris für diese kleine Impression aus Namibia. Wir haben anscheinend mehr Leute in Namibia, als wir dachten und wir hoffen, dass wir natürlich auch die anderen Länder damit spielen. Ja, ich dachte jetzt, es fängt irgendwie so an, als wir es aus dem Land was bekommen, aber wie es scheint, haben wir nur in Namibia so eine krasse Base. Naja, ich meine, wenn man da mit Deutsch gut durchkommt, ist ja das vielleicht auch naheliegend, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die Deutschen vielleicht nicht nur in dem einen Land unterhalten. Vielleicht gibt es da schon mehr. Aber ja, vielen Dank an unsere namibischen Außenreporter, sehr, sehr cool. Aber ich sage mal so, es wird hart, da im namibischen Radio Fuss zu fassen, weil die Konkurrenz ist stark.
Naja, denn auch ich habe gerade mal die Blutspendetermine hier in Deutschland rausgesucht und vielleicht können wir so ein bisschen Konkurrenz...
Die schweren Geschütze werden jetzt aufgefahren hier.
Naja, das ist natürlich schon interessant. Vielleicht sollten wir nach Namibia fahren.
Also auf jeden Fall würde ich sagen, dass ihr beiden jetzt die offiziellen Außenreporter, die Aussenkorrespondenten des Podcast-Ufos seid, aus Namibia, und dazu wurde die jetzt gerade befördert, finde ich. Also falls jemand in Namibia ist, dann rufen wir euch kurz an, da ist ja vielleicht sogar eine ähnliche Zeitzone, oder? Am Mittwoch, dem 20.11. könnt ihr im DRK Seniorenzentrum Holstenring 6 in Hamburg zwischen 15.30 und 19.30 Blutspenden. Cool. Also für alle Hamburger, geht doch mal vorbei, DRK Seniorenzentrum, 15.30 bis 19.30, ich denke, da ist für jeden was dabei, Holsteinring 6 am 20.11. ist Mittwoch, ja, nach Feierabend kommt man vorbei und gibt ein bisschen Blut ab.
In Köln könnt ihr zum Beispiel am 11.11., guter Tag auch dafür, am DRK Blutspendezentrum Köln am Neumarkt ein Stay von 12 bis 19 Uhr spenden, am Dienstag könnt ihr genau da auch von 12 bis 19 Uhr spenden, am Mittwoch in Köln-Worringen im Worringer Vereinshaus, fünfzehn, dreißig bis neunzehn Uhr und dann Mittwoch wieder wie gehabt im DRK-Bluespendezentrum. Jetzt haben wir auch gerade schon die Hymne gehört, ne? Toll! Ja, es ist fantastisch. Namibia, Land of the Brave, Freedom Fight, We Have Won, Glory to the Bravery, Whose Blood Waters Our Freedom whose blood waters our freedom ja ich glaube ich glaube nationale sind nicht immer die beste quelle um die individualität eines landes rauszustellen weil in der regel geht es immer um dieselben sachen we give our love and loyalty together in unity contrasting beautiful namibia nam, beloved land of Savanna, Savanna hold high the banner of liberty. Keine schlechte Hymne. We love thee. Das ist doch eine gute Hymne. Textlich nicht verwerflich dabei. Sie mögen ihre Savanne, das finde ich gut. Ich meine, es ist eine gute Hymne, aber ist es die beste Hymne Afrikas? Oh, das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Man muss echt sagen, die europäischen Hymnen sind da schon ganz schön weit, finde ich. Das sind gute Hymnen. Was ist denn eigentlich die neueste Hymne? Also welches Land auf der Welt hat die modernste Hymne? Spanien, aus welchem Jahr kommt er? Ich meine schon, dass die spanische Nationalhymne nicht so alt ist. So 2011 oder oder was? So Dubstep-mäßig.
Raggaeton einfach.
Warum haben wir uns auf Raggaeton festgelegt?
Ich habe gesagt, der Hype ist nach sechs Monaten
vorbei. Und jetzt bei jedem
Fussballspiel
Oh Gott.
Hier, das ist nämlich der Marcha Real
und der ist aus dem 19. Jahrhundert. Der ist noch nicht so
alt. Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, was die
neueste Nationalhymne ist. Vielleicht die Eurovisionshymne, auf der anderen Seite ist das aber auch, glaube ich, von einem französischen Komponisten, bin ich mir nicht sicher, finden wir heraus. Schlechte Nachrichten für alle Blutspendeinteressierten aus Mainz. Ich konnte keine Daten zu Blutspenden in Mainz finden, aber verzagt nicht, denn für alle, die vielleicht keine Lust auf Blutspende haben, sondern auf einen Live-Podcast. Für die kündigen wir an, dass es noch neue Tickets gibt für die Show in Mainz, vielleicht auch nicht mehr zu dem Punkt, wo wir es ausstrahlen. Ich glaube doch, denn da sind wir jetzt in einer deutlich grösseren Location, weil die Nachfrage dann doch sehr gross war und wir die Mainzer nicht enttäuschen wollten. Es bleibt natürlich weiterhin ein toller intimer Abend mit uns dreien, aber wir konnten jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr Leute unterbekommen und das ohne irgendwelche Richtlinien zu brechen, was die Kapazität der Menschen angeht oder irgendwelche Fluchtwege zuzustellen mit euch. Das perfekte Weihnachtsgeschenk, wenn ihr wisst, ich weiss noch nicht genau. Und wir haben mittlerweile auch natürlich, die Weihnachtsstimmung geht los, es wird kalt, kalt, kalt. Es wird richtig kalt, vor allem mir und meinen Füssen. Dir auch? Das ist das Schlimmste. Und wusstest du, dass man 60 Prozent der Körperwärme über die Füsse verliert? Ja, aber das sagen auch immer nur Schuhverkäufer oder Sockenverkäufer, dass genau wie Leute, die immer die Matratzen verkaufen, sagen, wusstest du, dass man 60 Prozent des Lebens schläft? Wo man irgendwann auch sagt, what the fuck, das sind doch irgendwie noch ausgedachte Zahlen. Und wenn du in den Hutladen gehst, sagst du, wussten sie, dass man 80% der Körperwärme über den Kopf fährt?
Nein, das ist doch völliger Unsinn. Der Schuster hat mal was ganz anderes gesagt.
Naja, jedenfalls gibt es die tollen neuen, das Podcast UFO Socken.
Yay!
Die sehen fantastisch aus. Bestellt euch ab sofort Socken. Ich glaube, die sind immer im Paar erhältlich. Dreier, man kriegt immer drei. Oh, das finde ich sehr clever. Oh, das fände ich super clever. Das fände ich gerade so clever, dass ich finde, wir sollten das machen. Man kriegt immer drei. Ja, so dass man sich mit einem anderen Hörer zusammentun muss. Genau, entweder wir verkuppeln so, oder man kauft sich dann zwei und wir ziehen euch das Geld aus der Tasche, weil es ja Sinn macht, dann doch lieber drei Paare zu haben.
Ja, oder halt als Ersatzsocke. Es passiert ja auch oft so, dass man eine Socke verliert und dann hat man so diesen eigentlich unschuldigen anderen Socken, der nichts falsch gemacht hat, aber man denkt sich, du musst jetzt sterben, weil eine Socke alleine bringt mir nichts. Also man reisst da immer so einen Unschuldigen mit, was eigentlich sehr tragisch ist, wenn man drei Socken hat, kann man einen verlieren, ja da kann man mal locker irgendwie nach dem Tennisunterricht mal locker die Socken in die Ecke werfen, egal wenn die hinter der Heizung landen, überhaupt kein Problem, man hat noch einen. Gar kein Problem, nee super, finde gute Idee. Sollten wir unbedingt machen. Es ist gerade diese Zeit des Jahres wieder, wo ich total gerne nachts abends zu Hause sitze, wie jetzt gerade, ist auch schon sehr spät, wir nehmen heute sehr spät auf, und irgendwann das Fenster aufmache und es kommt diese kalte Winterluft rein, aber innen drin sitzt man im Warm und so. Ich bin schon ein bisschen in der Weihnachtsstimmung, muss ich sagen, mittlerweile. Es ist herrlich und ich mag das, wenn es so früh dunkel wird, weil dann fühlt man sich, als hätte man mehr Zeit. Weil du bist so drauf gepolt, dass es nachts wird so 20 Uhr oder 22 Uhr und jetzt denkst du, oh scheiße, wie spät ist es denn? Und deine Lichtsensoren sagen dir, ja, es ist bestimmt schon so elf und du schaust auf die Uhr und es ist halt halb vier. Ja, halb vier und es ist halb vier. Und dann stehst du nachts auf und es ist Tag hell, es macht gar keinen Sinn mehr, nachts um zwei Uhr ist es Tag hell, habt ihr mal rausgeguckt, die denken, wir gucken nicht raus, das ist meine Verschwörungstheorie, man denkt, man guckt abends, geht man um nachts und guckt man raus, dann ist es Tag hell, das kann doch alles nicht wahr sein. Hier war auch letztens ein ganz merkwürdiger Feuerwehreinsatz und zwar kam da hier direkt in Hamburg bei einer Wohnung vorbei.
Hat ja uns versucht, mehr Schlauch, mehr Schlauch, schon wieder und hier wo ich wohne in Hamburg und dann kamen die durch die Strasse gefahren und so ein kompletter Löschzug, also so wirklich all in, so wirklich so das reiche Nachbarkind, das alle Feuerwehr Playmobil-Sets hat, alle, den Kleinwagen, den grossen Wagen, den Leiterwagen, den Pkw-Wagen mit dem Brandleiter drin, alles, so wirklich so die reichen Eltern, die sich versuchen, liebe Zeit kaufen. Warum darf der Brandleiter im eigenen Auto fahren? Ja, weil der nur manchmal kommt, das lohnt sich nicht, so das ist wie der Notarzt, der hat hat seinen eigenen Wagen. Also die gesamte Palette, aber ohne Sirenen. Also das war ein Einsatz, der die gesamte Kraft der Hamburger Feuerwehr erfordert hat. Aber keine Sirenen, Freunde. Wir wollen hier aber mit Blaulicht, aber keine Sirenen. Ich fand, das war so eine interessante, so wie, es brennt, es brennt. Ja, aber brennt es so richtig richtig oder können wir uns die Sirenen sparen? Ja, jetzt muss ich es so sagen, es ist schon, es ist okay. Brand bei Heckler und Koch oder so Brand in so einer NPD-Parteizentrale, wo man dann sagt, wir müssen hinfahren, aber müssen wir hinfahren. Oh, der Verkehr, der Stau, der kam nicht durch, war rot. Schwierig, das Schwimmbad brennt. Nochmal bitte, das Schwimmbad brennt. Okay, wir fahren mal los. Wir kommen rum, so schnell es geht. Wir beeilen uns. Ja, ja, wir beeilen uns. Ich wurde heute überholt von einem Krankenwagen, auch auf einer Autobahn. Und der kam und kam nicht vorbei, weil der ist 80 gefahren oder sowas. Das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden, weil ich bin dann rechts rüber, wie alle anderen auch, und ich dachte, bestimmt fünf Minuten habe ich in den Rückspiegel geguckt und der kam nicht. Und alle haben Platz gemacht und die ganze linke Spur war komplett frei und er hat voll Gas gegeben, ist aber 80 gefahren. Er war so langsam, dass ich irgendwann inzwischen dachte, jetzt ziehe ich wieder links rüber und fahre einfach, weil wir können hier locker 130 fahren gerade und niemand ist auf der Spur. Wie geil, das wäre meine Chance, schneller zur Arbeit zu kommen, aber dieser blöde Krankenwagen hat mit 80 über die Spur gekrebst. Was ist das denn für eine Quatsch? Ja, ja, aber ich meine, es muss ja auch Leute geben, die hinter ihm mit 130 gefahren sind, die ihn dann so weggehupt haben, so komm, gib Gas jetzt! Ja, mit so links geblinkt haben. Jetzt fahr doch mal rüber. Aber dann dachte ich mir wahrscheinlich... Bist du nicht kurz auf die Idee gekommen, dass du hinter ihn fährst und ihn so anschiebst, so dass du so deinen Teil dazu leistest und ihn schneller zum Zielort bringst? Habe ich kurz überlegt. Aber dann dachte ich mir, vielleicht ist da jemand drin, der gerade irgendwie wiederbelebt wird oder so oder wo, weiss ich nicht, irgendwas, was nicht wackeln soll doll. Die haben ja keine Gurte, oder? Haben die Gurte hinten? Doch, doch, doch, die haben Gurte. Und auch Helme, ne? Die haben Helme, die haben Gurte, die haben Knieschon, die haben alles da hinten. Alles ist so mit so Schaumstoff ausgekleidet, wie so eine Hüpfburg. Im Grunde ist es eine grosse Hüpfburg da hinten drin, ja. Macht Spaß, Krankenwagen macht Spaß. Wurdest du schon mal im Krankenwagen mitgenommen irgendwo hin? Nee, überhaupt gar nicht. Ich bin auch nicht Krankenwagen gefahren. Nichts. Ich bin wie gesagt einmal selbstständig im Car2Go zum Orthopäden gefahren, weil ich mir C gebrochen habe. Das war's. Das war die ganze Geschichte, mehr nicht.
Ja, ja. Nee, mir passiert das auch nicht. Wir müssen mal mehr erleben, dann passiert das auch mehr. Ich werde neulich mal sonntags Tennis spielen, weil ich frage mich ja, ich weiß ja nicht, was Menschen machen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe auch den, die, die komplett den Kontakt zu, zu normalen Menschen verloren, so wir leben in unseren komischen Elfenbein, Medien, Elfenbeintürmen, so. Was machen Menschen sonntags?
Die Stadt ist immer leer, ich bin immer der einzige Mensch, der sonntags auf der Strasse ist, wo sind die ganzen Menschen, habe ich mich gefragt, und dann haben Freunde und ich beschlossen, wir gehen Tennis spielen, mal, an einem schönen Sonntag in so einem Unizentrum, und da sind alle Menschen, da waren die ganzen, da sind die ganzen Sportler, da sind die ganzen Studenten, die machen alle Spielen, die Tennis oder Squash.
Bei Squash ist mir übrigens aufgefallen, ich kann mir, also wenn ich Squash sehe, sehe ich, dass die Sportart funktioniert. Sobald ich mich umdrehe und in die andere Richtung starre oder jetzt gerade hier zu Hause bin und nicht sehe, wie Menschen Squash spielen, kann ich mir nicht erklären, wie diese Sportart funktioniert. Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen. Ich kann mir Squash nicht vorstellen, weil ich kann mir das Sprungverhalten des Balles nicht vorstellen. Wie soll das funktionieren? Das ist ein ganz, ganz kleiner Raum, dann hauen die brachial mit diesen tennisartigen Schlägern, diese hart bespannten Schläger, hauen die da Badminton, kann ich mir vorstellen. So, aber Squash, wie soll das denn funktionieren? Das ist so ein Gummiball undall oder so ein ganz kleiner Raum, der irgendwie so drei Quadratmeter misst und dann hauen die da barial drauf und der Ball fliegt, muss doch, in meinem Kopf macht diese Sportart keinen Sinn.
Das ist die einzige Sportart, die ich mir nicht, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen.
Ich könnte zum Beispiel nicht mit Squash träumen, weil ich die ganze Zeit denke, der Ball müsste doch die ganze Zeit für zehn Minuten rumspringen und so. Es ist zu schnell, also ich kann mir, ich mag keine Sportarten, wo ein unbedarfter Zuschauer sich nicht freuen kann über einen Punkt. Es ist wirklich so, so Bats, Bats, oh! Aber in meinem Kopf... Was ist geschehen gerade? Und es klatscht nur ein Elternteil, was auf der Bühne sitzt. Ja, genau, aber ich kann mir viele Sportarten, eigentlich kann ich mir jede Sportart, glaube ich,, im Kopf zumindest so. Ich kann mir im Ballwechsel denken, beim Tischtennis, Badminton, alle schnelle Sportarten. Squash kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ist Fussball die Sportart, die am besten anschaubar ist? Ich glaube ja, ja, also ich glaube Baseball, Football, Basketball, Eishockey, die ganzen grossen Sportarten, die in den grossen Arenen gespielt werden, haben die perfekte Grösse, die perfekte Feldgrösse, die perfekte Ballgrösse, die kann man sich gut angucken. Ich glaube, bei Handball hört das schon so ein bisschen auf. Da scheiden sich ja die Geister an Handball. Ja, ist auch zu schnell, die werfen zu schnell. Nicht so viele Fans, zu viele Tore. Der Ball ist zu klein. Ja, ich finde, bei Fussball ist auch die Belohnung für ein Tor toll. Weil es ist ein sehr zufriedenstellendes Tor, weil es fällt in jedem Spiel ein paar Mal, durchschnittlich glaube ich so zweimal fällt ein Tor im Spiel. Und das ist so die perfekte Anzahl, weil du freust dich dadurch sehr über ein Tor. Beim Basketball fallen zu viele Körbe, beim Handball fallen zu viele Tore. Das macht es schon ganz gut, finde ich. Fussball macht schon vieles richtig, muss man sagen. Ist gut anzugucken. Auch die Feldgrösse ist toll für ein großes Stadion drumherum. Es passt genau in so eine 800-Meter-Laufbahn, das ist auch interessant. Ja, es gibt schon echt merkwürdige Sportarten. Ich habe jetzt auch so einen Bogenschützen-Beitrag gesehen, und da gibt es dann immer so Zweierteams. Und Bogenschießen ist ja so eine Sportart, wo du eigentlich es egal ist und du alleine es betrachtest. Oder auf, also alleine schiessen und für Olympiaschießen ist exakt gleich. Du hast keinen Gegner, der dich irgendwie behindert oder sowas, das zu machen, was du machen willst. Es ist exakt gleich. Und damit die es halt interessanter machen, gibt es so dieses Team, wo ich mir immer denke, so einer zieht den anderen runter. Es gibt kein Zweierteam, wo immer beide gleich gut sind. Es muss immer einen geben, dass ich denke, oh Gott, du bist der einzige andere Algerier, der professionell Bogen schießt. Ich muss jetzt mit dir hier schießen und du ziehst mich einfach super runter. Jetzt freue ich mich auf den Hassbeitrag aus Algerien. Ach ja, wir sind gute Bogenschützen. Kann schon sein, kann schon sein. Kann schon sein, ja, das stimmt schon. Auch Michael Phelps muss ja gedacht haben, bei jedem Mitschwimmer bei so einem Staffelschwimmen muss er gedacht haben, oh fuck, weil er ist der beste Schwimmer gewesen. So, es ist immer, er ist immer der Beste. Das ist auch blöd dann für so eine Staffel. Es gab doch jetzt auch bei der letzten irgendwie Saudi-Arabien-Olympiade, keine Ahnung, da gab es da diesen Skandal, dass in den Startblöcken von den Sprintern im Startblock eine Kamera ist, die dann so von unten nach oben filmt, das Gesicht des Athleten, wenn er startet. Da haben sich dann weibliche Athleten beschwert, weil das halt irgendwie ungünstiger Winkel ist, so direkt von unten zwischen Weine gefilmt zu werden. Und man sich denkt so, was soll der Scheiss? Aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, wie der Kameramann so sagt so, ja Leute, was soll ich denn machen? Es ist halt visuell nicht so mega, also ihr könnt ja auch mal irgendwie ein Salto machen oder so oder was soll ich denn machen? Es ist halt nur laufend. Zieht euch mal bunte Sachen an oder wenigstens.
Ja, ich meine, ich meine, ich habe euch vorgeschlagen, dass wir die GoPros umschnallen, da habt ihr gesagt nein, dann habe ich gesagt vielleicht Wölfe hinter euch, da habt ihr auch gesagt nein.
Wie gesagt, ich habe hier drei Kostüme.
Jetzt habe ich euch eine Kamera in die Hose gesteckt, das ist ausschallt egal.
Ich habe hier vier Kostüme vorgeschlagen, bei jedem habt ihr gesagt, nein, mir gehen die Ideen aus.
Und wenn ihr immer nur nein sagt, ja, dann können wir es auch lassen an der Stelle. So, ich gebe mir Mühe, aber immer nein. Es ist schwierig, vor allem dann gibt es ja, finde ich ja beim Sprinten, diesen einen Shot von vorne, also wo die Sprinter nebeneinander stehen. Ein Shot, der einem nichts sagt, weil man sieht nicht, wer vorne ist und wer hinten ist.
Du siehst halt einfach zehn schwitzende Menschen nebeneinander.
Und dann denkst du dir, gut, da kann ich auch ein Spiel schauen.
Vielen Dank auch. Da kann ich auch Werbung gucken.
Guck ich lieber Werbung.
Ich verstehe die Popularität auch nicht bei 100 Meter Läufen.
Weil das ist einfach, das ist doch scheiße. Das, ganz kurz nur, unter zehn Sekunden dauert das. Man guckt es sich auch nicht gerne an, weil es passiert ja auch nicht, es ist selten spannend. Es gibt selten immer, es gibt häufig einen krassen Favoriten, es ist sehr schnell vorbei und die meiste Zeit ist Wiederholung. Ich finde Sportarten, wo man die meiste Zeit Wiederholungen sieht, von dem eigentlichen Ereignis, ist es problematisch schon. Bin ich kein Fan von. Ja, ich kann schon verstehen, dass man da als Medienbeauftragter von so einer Olympiade ein bisschen struggelt und sich Sachen überlegt. Aber ja, es war natürlich keine gute Idee. Oder so ein Twitter-Social-Media-Team von Michael Phelps beim Schwimmen oder halt von Usain Bolt ist halt doof. Das hat nur zehn Sekunden, wenn du so einen Ticker machst. Ja, stimmt schon. Heute einen Live-Ticker vom 100-Meter-Rennen und vorbei, gewonnen, der hatte gewonnen. Ich meine, wie wäre es denn zum Beispiel zu sagen, die zehn Renner, okay, cool, aber dann stell doch da mal nochmal so einen Hasen dazu. Und lass den auch mitrennen und einfach nur mal, um zu gucken ... Ob Menschen schneller sind als Hasen. Ja, das muss nicht mal der schnellste Hase sein. Nö, ein Hasen. Einfach nur irgendein, irgendein random Hase. Egal, was welchen Hase. Ja, nebenbei noch was zu lernen. Oder er zeigt nebenbei, spielt einen Song. Oder spielt nebenbei, lasst den Ton von so einer Werner Herzog-Dokumentation laufen. Oder so, ist ja auch scheißegal. Hauptsache, dass man noch ein bisschen was mitnehmen kann. Ja, oder mach dann so noch die Schallgeschwindigkeit, so als Anschauungsbeispiel. Oh, so schnell wäre die jetzt gewesen. Wäre der Schall gewesen. Oder halt einfach noch einen normalen Menschen mitlaufen lassen, der halt dann einfach, wo man denkt, wow, die sind echt fucking schnell. Olli P oder so, dass allen normalen, ganz normalen Menschen mitlaufen lassen, der halt dann einfach, wo man denkt, wow, die sind echt fucking schnell. Olli P oder so, das ist ein normalen, ganz normalen Menschen mitlaufen, wo man mal vergleichen kann, weil das ist ja auch so ein Ding, du hast ja keine Referenz, du weißt ja nicht, wie schnell wäre ich denn da jetzt gerade, so einen Dicken, einfach mal gucken, das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, Florian Züge. Olli P und dann aber auch noch so einer auf dem Pferd, irgendwie so, und dann irgendwie keiner, vielleicht noch so Radfahrer. Einfach so mal alle gegeneinander und dann so eine Kutsche. Einen Radfahrer nebenan stellen. Ja, ich finde das eine gute Idee. Einfach um den Sport mal ein bisschen spannender zum Kutschen. Snipe. Ja, das ist so ein E-Scooter. Da hat mittlerweile auch jeder das Gefühl, wie schnell die Dinger sind. Ja, oder irgendwie einer von, oder vielleicht mach mal so, erst rennen alle und der, der gewinnt, muss in der nächsten Runde rückwärts laufen. Und man guckt, ob er immer noch gewinnen würde. Und wenn er das schafft, dann muss er auf allen Vieren laufen. Einfach ein bisschen mehr weint. Ja, oder er hat so leicht schwerere Schuhe an oder so, ungünstigere Schuhe. Ja, genau. Muss den, muss den letztplatzierten tragen. Ja, das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Da fällt uns was ein. Ja, meine Rangliste übrigens ist meine E-Scooter-Rangliste, Anbieter-Rangliste, wäre jetzt. Auf Platz 1 haben wir noch Cirque, unangefochten, auf Platz 2 Tier, auf Platz 3 Bird, auf Platz 4 Lime. Das wäre meine Reihenfolge. Aber da bin ich auch offen.
Ich bin immer noch E-Scooter-Jungfrau, ich habe das nicht mitbekommen.
Immer noch nicht.
Ich habe nichts davon mitbekommen.
Ich bin ja eigentlich Fan von diesen E-Rollern, aber so wie Vespa-Rollern, also die grossen, wo man so drauf sitzt.
Und dann war ich ja Kunde von Emmy, diese roten Roller, wo immer die Helme hinten drin sind, da kann man die sich rausholen. Die haben jetzt in ihrer App eine Herbst- und Winterpause angekündigt. Herbst und Winter sind keine Dienste mehr verfügbar, es gibt keine Roller mehr. Und warum nicht? Frost. Nee, die haben alle ihre Batterien in einem Lagerhaus gelagert und es abgebrannt. Oh, okay. Alles abgebrannt. Und so wie ich die Geschichte gehört habe, haben die sich dann gedacht, na ja, fuck, ist schon dumm, alle Akkus in einem Lagerhaus zu lagern, lass uns die in mehreren Häusern lagern. Und dann sind die auch nochmal alle abgebrannt. Ob das stimmt, weiß ich nicht, aber ich finde die Geschichte gut. Gute Geschichte, ja. Es ist aber so ein bisschen, jetzt tatsächlich habe ich auch auf der App nachgeschaut, nähester Roller irgendwie so 36 Stunden entfernt in einer anderen Stadt oder so. Okay, gut, lassen wir das. Aber ja, es kann schlecht ausgehen, weil ich war ein bisschen abhängig von denen. Jetzt muss ich laufen. Die guten alten Füsse mal wieder. Gibt es dafür eine App, sich die Füsse zu leihen oder was? Kann ich mir Füsse von anderen leihen? Da hat man übernachtgedacht. Man ist schneller zu Fuss am Ziel, als man denkt. Wirklich. Man denkt, man unterschätzt es. Man geht ganz schön schnell. Und ich gehe mittlerweile gerne, weil man auch da immer gut Zeit hat, Podcasts zu hören.
Ihr könnt immer sagen, ich mache bis zu einem 30-Minuten-Heimweg nach der Arbeit, immer schön um Podcasts zu hören oder zum Beispiel sich eine tolle Netflix-Serie anzugucken.
Nebenbei ganz fantastisch. Kleine Empfehlung für die Woche, hast du Bock?
Habe ich Bock drauf, hau raus, muss immer was gut sein.
Serienempfehlung, einmal natürlich erstens der Film Booksmart. Ich weiß nicht, ob du dich erinnerst, aber wir waren in UCB und da war ein Schauspieler zu Gast. Genau, der spielt auch mit in Booksmart, schaut euch den Film Booksmart an, ist eine klassische Teenager-Highschool-Romcom, sehr klassisch, aber gut gemacht und auf Netflix die Dokureihe Der Teufel wohnt nebenan. Unfassbare Dokuserie.
Cool, da freuen wir auch schon drauf. Über jemanden, der angeklagt wird, in einem KZ Wärter gewesen zu sein, aber man weiß nicht, ob er es wirklich war oder nicht und der ist jetzt schon alt und es ist fucking weird, wie sich diese Geschichte entwickelt, es ist großartig, deine Empfehlungen. Ich möchte empfehlen Parasite. Schaut euch diesen Film im Kino an, hat die goldene Palme von Cannes gewonnen, ist ein koreanischer Film und es ist ein verdammt guter Film. Also ich war schon zweimal im Kino, ich kann den empfehlen, es ist so unglaublich lustig, toll geschrieben, ein super spannender, unglaublich lustiger Film, Parasite im Kino anschauen.
Cool. Wir wünschen euch eine
fantastische Woche, viel Spaß und wir hören uns
nächste Woche wieder, wenn es wieder heisst,
das Podcast-Ufo. Wir heben ab.
Mach's gut.